don't bring anyone love into this well
speaking of dog come and be vomiting yes
great thanks speaking of dog coming
vomiting Jesus Christ what what kind of
segue what are we gonna go into now I
thought it makes total sense how louis
c.k has been now he's one of the the
titans of art of our industry and and
you know obviously if you were alive you
paid attention to it probably if you
follow comedy and like comedy podcasts
you're probably well versed in already
but yeah there's this um you know
there's this shakedown going down that's
probably the wrong term but there's this
cheese shake down just down that's going
down in Hollywood no it's overall I
think it's it's actually a really good
thing it's like checking some pretty
horrible behavior and behavior that's
been known by the way in our community
for a long time yeah and I'm talking
about I mean when I say checking
behavior I'm talking about across the
board I think it's good to check
powerful people that are abusing their
power yeah and I think obviously the
Weinstein one is massive and he's over
he's been raping people he crazy and
then you know I made some jokes
initially about the Spacey one yeah
because I you know not that it's
whatever it's not it's not like a good
thing he was doing but I thought he was
just kind of being you know overly
flirtatious on the set like kind of like
I said he's like rubbing guys shoulders
that don't want I was like oh he's just
he's doing what some guys do to women
but two guys on the set of house of
cards and then stories came out about
him with like fourteen-year-old boys
Yanks attempting to rape one supposedly
raping another and turns out I mean at
least how it's being portrayed is that
he's a fucking savage you know and I
think those guys will
never work again and should never work
again and some and I think you know I
think Weinstein might go to prison I
hope so active investigation he's a real
predator there's open cases on him in LA
and New York yeah so they're like there
and they're investigating trying to find
a way to charge that guy with a real
crime yeah well you know what let's I
mean he did go to rehab for three whole
days huh so let's not forget him and
space here at the same place do you know
that they're in the same rehab facility
yeah good for them can compare comparing
notes but what's that shit shithead that
raped a 13 year old and he went to Paris
Oh Roman Polanski yeah and has been
continued to yeah they celebrated
business loves that guy welcome back
like what I wonder if they're going to
further you know like he's been he's
been defended by show business people
for a long time I know one of the more
alarming things if you don't know the
Polanski store you can read it in detail
but he was convicted in Los Angeles
County of sex with a 13 year old girl
and a hot tub that he gave champagne - I
don't know he gave her a pill he you
know had an agreement of a certain
amount of time to be served the judge
either retired or died and so like the
replacement judge was like no no you're
gonna go to prison for a while and his
his defense I'm paraphrasing this stuff
but like was something about yeah but
the last last judge said we had a deal
and basically new judge was like I don't
give a fuck about your deal yeah and so
he got on a plane to Paris and that's
that he's never come back he's tried to
ask for permission to come back and Los
Angeles District Attorney's for the last
whatever 30 years have been like nope
you have an open warrant for your arrest
if you're ever and yeah you know around
US territories or anyplace anyways all
that stuff those guys are it's horrible
with Louie you know the thing that first
of all was just like we've heard the
stories for a long time you know
particularly yeah one it's it's let's
put it this way
it's it's been in our industry we've all
known the comedians have spoken about
your glass I thought it was one of the
things I'm like hmm is hearing some of
these comics go like I didn't know well
the thing is - you hear stories like the
his peer like guys are his age right
right oh they yeah come on go around you
didn't know that really I mean the thing
is - but but you know again if you're in
our shoes and you hear a story like that
about somebody you don't you weren't
there you don't know all the facts you
don't know you don't know what's true
what's not what's you know what I mean
like stories the telephone game is like
okay I don't know I don't you don't know
I know nothing I don't know I here's the
thing about my thought on it is that
what he did is not okay to do clearly
it's really not okay to do that to
people especially if like those people
are you know like in a position working
for something like if they're working
under you and like you're the boss
basically in the room right that's the
whole thing is that he was in there
there you know he's in the position of
power yeah I'm taking advantage of his
powerful position it's fucked up it is
it is fucked up yeah but again like is
it is it worth ruining someone's entire
life you're like dude I have a lot I
know I don't know how this I mean if it
comes across really callous but like
when that story broke and when the
consequences started you know coming to
be I felt like a lot of empathy for that
guy not because I thought it was okay
what he did but like I just started
thinking about somebody with you know
he's got two kids like two daughters and
I'm like and I know that the answer to
that is like well maybe you shouldn't
have fucking done that then yeah I get
it and I'm not I'm not defending it or
minimizing or diminishing what he did
but it is you know I can't help but like
I feel like that is a fucking
devastating price to pay you know it is
and I think to write like all crimes
different levels of crime you have
first-degree murder second-degree murder
manslaughter manslaughter assault
aggravated yeah I think right now like
to lump him in with a Harvey Weinstein
not okay to do that it's not the same
crime now is it a crime absolutely is it
is it horrible and traumatic to have to
go through something like that with a
dude yeah of course
and honestly how many of the woman have
I seen dudes doing that in public
yeah every since I was 12 an awake
husband dudes doing that I've never said
this publicly yeah I have my own
experience right with a person who I
worked for very early on in my show
business career or living in Los Angeles
and it was for working for somebody in a
position of power who did something in a
very inappropriate and I've told you
about I don't wanna get in the diesel
yeah I don't want to out the person
either because I don't know what the the
end game that I'm looking for right you
know it's just like it's kind of one of
those things where I just chalked it up
to being like that person's fucked up
and they have their own demons and you
know I don't know what's gonna happen to
them but yeah it's been a long time it's
been a long time right yeah I just know
man it's so fucked up I think what
really breaks your heart and it breaks
our hearts I think you and I pacifically
yeah is that Louie is such a super
talent too and you go like retard man
that's the guy we all we all look up to
as the gold standard it's one of those
things that people always you know bring
up up with these super talents that have
these flaws or these you know like like
your Polanski is obviously a great
director Ryan you know Michael Jackson
was one obviously like the whole world
yeah celebrated his talent and then
there was like is he fucking kids all
the time like it's crazy Mark Kelly are
Kelly's yeah for sure
you know he's a real talk man he really
it's it's confusing and I think it Cosby
was the worst cuz you're at the same as
a fan like let's take it back as a fan
of these people it's it's such a
psychological mind fun you're like wait
am I allowed to like this person anymore
I think the other part of it the facts
people like us with regard to Louie
is that where we work in his field yeah
like you know Cosby seems so separated
from us because he's like 50 years older
right and like the way he came up but
like we have like a certain bond with
Louie because Louie's kind of like the
talent-wise and like the kind of The
Cosby of our era like the class ahead of
us he's the class ahead of us but we've
seen him like we remember him having his
first special yeah and seeing the
trajectory seeing the build and so in a
way he's like he's like the big brother
even of comedians who aren't friends
with him let you go like wow like what
I'm doing this and this and this you
know so it's like you kind of want to
we've all kind of been like in all even
if he's not you're like I know some
people are like you know content wise
they're not like into him or whatever
look man objectively skill wise he's
such a skilled comedian yes it's it's
wild yeah it's a fucking bummer dude
there's the whole thing I mean it's sad
I feel like that it happened like it's
sad that he did that and and sad for the
women that experience but I'm also sad
at the like someone's you know life
being just totally ruined totally
devastated right now yeah fine
and they tried you know and lumping in
the people close to him making it about
like his manager that's all about that
stuff to your lake we'll look the
manager is only going by what he's been
told yeah by the client and it's the
manager's job to protect the client so
you can't you can't be like hey the
manager should have known there's a lot
of things they're not omnipotent yeah
like you know what a mislead the person
that you're wanting to help you cover
for it
so he's not going that I did he's gonna
be like I didn't really you know you've
court he's gonna minimize of most likely
and if you have a good manager they're
gonna fucking try to help you yeah
they're gonna help you out of the mud so
and he wasn't anyway he wasn't helping a
superstar
that's right at the time people are like
yeah of course you're gonna protect this
was fuckin a long time ago so I mean I'm
not like I know people are already gonna
jump on us for the way that we're
phrasing this I guess but I just feel
like part of what's going on right now
is there's like a hysteria which again
the end result is that it's gonna it's
gonna check people in power to really
think twice before they yes and this is
a good thing and this is a necessary
move in the evolution of equality for
women this is a necessary I mean okay
but it is a necessary thing to do to
start weeding out these jerk-offs that
are abusing women abusing and molesting
children by the way Cory Feldman's
coming out and naming people who in the
80s were molesting and he said this is a
known thing that they're a power to that
came out against Spacey he was 14 yeah I
mean there's a fourteen-year-old boy and
that's fuckin unbelievable but it's it
is it is a necessary thing to get things
more equal and to clean up the business
a little bit you know
yeah it's it's terrible the whole thing
is devastating
it's terrible men I don't know dick I'll
make you slap somebody to fame know
about the truth right yeah
[Music]